day two of the st. Louis rabbit and  Flint a historic event in the world of  chess the fourth tournament of the 2017  branches' tour featured more exciting  drama as the world's best players tried  to play themselves into top form former  world champion Garry Kasparov had great  positions in all of his games but slow  play in critical moments left him with a  minor score at the end of the day 20  years news industry industry Yanni from  the achi became the first player in over  a decade to defeat too far up in  professional competitions and that  victory have catapult the Russian to  finish the day in clear first place and  likely to attendance  that's already something it's the last  day of the rapids with six potential  points up for grabs day three of action  starting right now